UNETHICAL AND AT SOME POINT WE
WILL FIND REAL ILLEGAL ACTIVITY.
JOINING US NOW A FORMER DEPUTY
ASSISTANT AND FLORIDA ATTORNEY
GENERAL PAM.
PAM, THOUGHTS?
>> OH, SEAN, IF WE WERE WATCHING
THIS ON A MOTIVE, I DON'T THINK
ANYONE WOULD BELIEVE IT.
WHAT FOX UNCOVERED.
FIRST ALL OF THESE PEOPLE NEED
TO BE WIPED OFF THE CASE AND
START OVER.
THERE IS NO QUESTION ABOUT THAT.
I WILL SAY THIS EVERY TIME.
THIS IS OUT OF CONTROL.
I THINK SANCHEZ ASKED GREAT
QUESTIONS TODAY.
AND ROD ROSENSTEIN, I HAVE DEALT
WITH HIM.
I HAD ETHICAL DEALINGS WITH ROD.
HE SAID IT'S THE RESPONSIBILITY
TO BE SURE INFLUENCE --
>> Sean: WHAT ELSE DO WE NEED?
>> TO GET ALL OF THESE OTHER
PEOPLE OFF THE CASE.
I THINK HE IS ETHICAL.
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> Sean: HE THINK MUELLER IS
DOING A GOOD JOB.
>> I THINK WE NEED TO HOLD ON
AND SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
I AM NOT DEFENDING MUELLER.
I AM NOT DEFENDING ROSENSTEIN.
WHAT I AM SAYING IS GIVEN
EVERYTHING YOU EXPOSED, GIVEN
ALL OF THESE PEOPLE NEED TO BE
WIPED OUT.
THERE ARE PLENTY OF GOOD PEOPLE
OUT THERE WHO CAN HANDLE A CASE
WHO HAVE NO INFLUENCE.
THEY HAVEN'T GIVEN TO EITHER
PARTY.
8 OUT OF THE 16 PEOPLE NOT ONLY
DONATEED TO DEMOCRATS BUT VERY
ACTIVE IN THE ANTI-TRUMP
MOVEMENT.
THEY ALL NEED TO BE GONE.
IF THEY ARE TALKING ABOUT MCCABE
THERE COULD BE CRIMMIAL ISSUES.
>> Sean: DR. SEBASTIAN GORKA,
HOW DO WE INTERRUPT THE
INSURANCE POLICY THEY DISCUSSED
WITH WHO WE THINK IS ANDREW
MCCABE?
MANUFACTURE TRUMP AND RUSSIAN
COLLUSION AND THAT WILL BE IN
THE MEANS TO TAKE OUT THE
ELECTED PRESIDENT?
TRUMP.
>> I ONLY INTERRUPT WHAT
INDIVIDUAL WORDS IN THE TEXT
MESSAGES MEAN.
WE HAVE ENOUGH EVIDENCE ALREADY.
I HAVE TO DISAGREE WITH PAM.
IT'S ABOUT DISSOLVING THIS TEAM.
THIS TEAM, MUELLER'S TEAM IS
MANNED BY MEMBERS OF HILLARY
CLINTON'S RESISTANT MOVEMENT.
THERE IS A REASON THAT LADY
JUSTICE IS BLINDFOLDED.
IN THIS CASE SHE TOOK THE
BLINDFOLD OFF AND USING THAT
SWORD TO ATTACK THE PRESIDENT.
WHERE IS PETER STRZOK TODAY?
THE SECOND THESE TEXT MESSAGES
HE IS IN THE HR-DEPARTMENT OF
THE BUREAU.
THINK ABOUT WHAT YOU CAN DO IN
THAT DEPARTMENT.
HE IS MASSAGING DOCUMENTS?
IS HE HIDING THE POLITICAL
IDENTITIES OF OTHER PEOPLE
INVESTIGATING THE PRESIDENT?
THIS IS NOT POLITICAL BIAS.
THIS IS CORRUPTION AT THE
HIGHEST LEVEL OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
>> Sean: HOW CAN THEY LOOK AT
THE TEAM OF CLINTON LOVERS,
TRUMP HATERS, THE UNETHICAL
BEHAVIOR OF WISEMAN.
AND WE HEAR THAT THERE IS NO WAY
TRUMP GETS ELECTED, BUT I AM
AFRAID WE CAN'T TAKE THAT RISK.
IT'S LIKE AN INSURANCE POLICY IN
CASE YOU DIE BEFORE YOU ARE 40.
DEEP STATE POWERFUL OPERATIVES,
PLOTTING AND PLANING TO
UNDERMINE AN ELECTION.
TELL ME WHY I AM WRONG, PAM
BONDI.
>> NO, SEBASTIAN GORKA, YOU USED
MUCH BETTER WORDS THAN I.
THEY NEED TO BE DISSOLVED.
I AM HOLDING OUT HOPE THAT ROD
ROSENSTEIN --
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING]
>> Sean: WHY DIDN'T SEE?
>> I CAN TELL YOU.
THEY AGREE WITH THAT.
>> Sean: COMEY AND STRZOK
EXONERATED HILLARY CLINTON ON
THE EMAIL SERVER INVESTIGATION
BEFORE THE INVESTIGATION.
THAT SOUNDS LIKE OBSTRUCTION TO
COMEY IS INTERRUPT.
-- THEY ARE CORRUPT.
COMEY IS CORRUPT.
STRZOK IS CORRUPT.
COMEY WILL SKATE ALONG TRYING TO
MAKE EVERYBODY HAPPY.
HE WON'T CHANGE THE CORRUPT
NATION OF THIS TEAM.
MUELLER IS A VIETNAM VET BUT
MAYBE HE IS TONE DEAF.
YOU CAN'T HAVE 10 PEOPLE THAT
ARE IN THE TANK FOR HILLARY
INVESTIGATE THE REPUBLICAN
PRESIDENT WHO DEFEATED HILLARY.
>> Sean: I WILL GIVE YOU ANOTHER
EXAMPLE.
WHAT ABOUT THE DOSSIER?
FOUR DOORS DOWN FROM ROSENSTEIN
IS BRUCE OHR MEETING WITH FUSION
GPS AS THIS IS GOING ON.
HIS WIFE IS DOING ANTI-TRUMP
RESEARCH FOR THEM.
FOUR DOORS DOWN.
TRUMP AND RUSSIAN COLLUSION?
CAMPAIGN TO INFLUENCE THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
IS THAT COLLUSION?
>> PAM?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
YOU CAN'T BLAME ROSENSTEIN JUST
BECAUSE HIS OFFICE IS FOUR DOORS
I HOPE HE WILL DO THE RIGHT
THING.
I KNOW HIM.
I HAVE WORKED WITH HIM.
ALL OF THESE PEOPLE NEED TO BE
DISSOLVED OFF OF THIS
INVESTIGATION.
HE SAID WE WILL SEE SOMETHING
SOON.
I AM HOPEFUL WE WILL BE SEEING
THAT BECAUSE HE IS SUPERVISING
MUELLER.
>> Sean: THIS IS WORST THAN
WATERGATE.
>> I AGREE.
>> Sean: MASSIVE WEB OF
CORRUPTION.
IT'S WATERGATE ON HUMAN GROWTH
HORMONE AND STEROIDS.
>> AND YOU HAVE TO UNTANGLE.
>> Sean: AND THE MEDIA IS STILL
EVIDENCE.
>> I DOUBT WE WOULD HAVE TODAY'S
HEARING WITHOUT YOU, SEAN.